Prof: Good morning
everybody.
In the one hundred years
between A.D.
98 and A.D.
192, Rome had five emperors:
Trajan,
Hadrian, Antonius Pius,
Marcus Aurelius and Commodus --
six if we count Lucius Verus,
who was co-emperor with Marcus
Aurelius for several years.
In the fifty years following
the death of the last of the
Severan emperors,
a young man by the name of
Alexander Severus,
who died in 235 A.D.,
Rome had twenty acknowledged
emperors,
and many more pretenders to
imperial power.
Rarely did anyone hold onto
power for more than a few years,
and some of them lasted only a
matter of months.
I like to think of the emperors
as changing as quickly as the
seasons, in the third century
A.D.
Any wrong move led to
assassination and replacement,
not by the Senate,
but by the provincial armies,
by the provincial armies.
Civil wars were extremely
commonplace in the third century
A.D.,
and it was a very bad time for
the Roman emperors,
who could literally be stabbed
in the back at any moment;
and many of them were.
The Roman frontiers were in
danger,
the economy was in shambles,
and the vast bureaucracy was
also suffering significantly in
the third century A.D.,
largely because of a lack of
central control.
In view of this chaotic
situation, there was very little
time to build buildings,
which is obviously what's
significant to us,
in the context of this course.
In many ways I think one can
describe, vis-à-vis
architecture,
the third century A.D.
as essentially a wasteland,
an architectural wasteland.
There were no forums in the
third century A.D.
There were no basilicas and
there were no baths.
We will see that the major
project in the third century
A.D.
was not unexpectedly,
given this situation,
a major defensive wall.
That was the main architectural
commission in the third century
A.D.,
and it's with that wall that I
want to begin today,
the so-called Aurelian Walls.
Before I do,
I just want to give you a
glimpse of two of those twenty
acknowledged emperors who made
their way through the third
century A.D.:
the boy emperor,
Gordian III,
on the left-hand side of the
screen,
and the more mature emperor,
Pupienus,
who was co-emperor with a man
by the name of Balbinus,
for a very short time.
And, in fact,
just to give you a sense of the
flavor of the third century,
both of them were dragged from
the palace,
not too long after they had
ascended to imperial power,
murdered and their bodies
tossed in the Tiber River.
If you look at these two
portraits,
one of the boy emperor and one
of the more mature emperor,
even though many,
many years separate them in
chronological age,
I think you will see,
if you look at the way in which
these portraitists represented
their eyes,
in the likenesses of these two
individuals,
in these official portraits of
Gordion and of Pupienus,
I think you'll see,
if you look at those eyes,
that those eyes reveal the
concern that these emperors had
for the state of the Empire
during the third century A.D.:
a concern that was extremely
warranted, obviously.
So again I want to begin with
the only significant
architectural project in the
third century A.D.
in Rome, and that is this great
defensive wall system called the
Aurelian Walls.
The Aurelian Walls were built
for two main reasons:
one,
because the earlier walls,
the so-called Servian Walls,
which we studied at the very
beginning of the semester,
which date to the Republic--378
B.C.
is when they were dedicated;
so way, way back in the
beginning of our discussion of
Roman architecture--
you'll remember that those
Servian Walls--
and I can show it to you with
this plan here of the walls
during ancient Roman times--
the Servian Walls encircled
just the Seven Hills of Rome.
So this central area here,
where we see the Palatine,
the Capitoline,
the Caelian,
the Quirinal Hill,
that was the location of that
original Servian Wall.
As the city grew,
as the population grew,
as more people were brought
back to Rome,
through the various wars and
through the enslavement of large
numbers of people,
the city grew significantly in
size.
And so by this time,
by the third century,
the Servian Wall was
essentially useless to protect
Rome from those barbarians that
were literally at the gates at
this particular point in Roman
history,
so they needed to build that
wall to protect the city.
But the other reason was
because of what was going on,
on the frontiers,
because Rome was more in danger
than it had ever been before.
Because of the kind of
political and economic situation
in Rome that I've just
described,
there was a need for further
stability and the need to build
this second set of walls:
again,
the so-called Aurelian Walls.
And this plan shows you how
much further out they went than
the Servian Walls,
all the way to the Tiber River.
It didn't encompass the area
across the Tiber,
where Hadrian's tomb,
Hadrian's mausoleum,
the Castel Sant'Angelo is
located, but for the most part
it did cover the main of the
city.
And you can see,
it went far enough out that it
even encompassed some of the
major city roads,
or the beginnings of some of
those major city roads.
A view of the Aurelian Walls
itself,
very well preserved,
here on the right-hand side of
the screen,
and a comparison of them with
the Servian Walls,
on the left.
With regard to the Aurelian
Walls, they are named for the
emperor Aurelian,
who was emperor of Rome between
270 and 275 A.D.
We believe that Aurelian began
the walls, either in 270 or 271.
They were not finished by his
death in 275,
and they were completed by his
successor, a man by the name of
Probus, P-r-o-b-u-s;
Probus completed the Aurelian
Walls, and dedicated them right
after Aurelian's death,
in 275 A.D.
The Aurelian Walls had a
twelve-mile circuit around the
city of Rome.
They were originally 25 and one
half feet tall,
and there were eighteen major
gateways in the Aurelian Walls;
eighteen major gateways.
I think you can see from this
view on the right-hand side of
the screen that the building
materials were concrete faced
with brick --
brick-faced concrete.
You see that very clearly here.
And, of course,
it's important to keep in mind
that that is different than what
the original Republican walls
were made out of.
Those were made out of
cut-stone, ashlar blocks.
You see them here in this
section of the Servian Walls,
that I show you once again,
blocks that are laid in the
scheme of headers and
stretchers,
that we talked about at the
very beginning of the semester,
when we discussed early Roman
wall building,
both in Rome and in the early
colonies.
And here again the Aurelian
Walls, with their up-to-date
concrete faced with brick.
But it's a sign of the times
that scholars who have examined
these bricks have determined
that they were not all new
bricks,
that many of them were re-used
bricks from earlier periods,
from the previous century in
particular.
And the reason for that
probably has to do with the fact
that again because there was so
little architectural activity
during this period there was
simply no need to make bricks in
large numbers,
and when they needed them for
this particular project,
they reached back and used some
that had been lying around of
earlier manufacture.
So I think again that
underscores the incertitude of
this particular period of time.
Here's another very good view
of the Aurelian Walls,
as they look today,
brick-faced concrete
construction once again.
And what's impressive about the
Aurelian Walls is how much of
them are preserved.
When I showed you the Servian
Walls,
we could only look at bits and
pieces of those walls,
preserved in different parts of
Rome,
especially near the Rome train
station.
But in the case of the Aurelian
Walls,
we have a very large extent of
those walls still preserved
today,
which is a tribute to how well
they were built,
that they have stood the test
of time.
And, in fact,
when one visits Rome,
when you come into Rome from
Leonardo da Vinci Airport,
the first things that you see
of the city are the walls.
You go through those walls and
it announces to you,
of course, that you are in fact
about to enter the city of Rome.
I mentioned that the Aurelian
Walls had eighteen gateways.
Some of them are still
preserved, and I want to show
you one of them here,
just to give you a sense of
what these gateways were like.
This is the so-called Porta
Appia.
It also dates to the same time
as the walls,
275 A.D.; called the Porta
Appia because it is at the exact
location of the Via Appia,
or the Appian Way in Rome.
The gate--I'm going to show you
how the gate looked in the time,
in 275, and then how it was
altered somewhat later.
You can see from the Monument
List that although it was built
originally in 275,
it was restored by two
Byzantine emperors by the name
of Honorius and Arcadius,
so this is in the post-Roman
period,
and they did that in A.D.
401 to 402.
And the gate,
as you see it today,
extremely well preserved,
is the gate of the restoration
of the fifth century A.D.;
whereas this view,
this restored view from
Ward-Perkins,
shows you what the gate
would've looked like in 275.
In 275 it had two arcuated
entranceways,
as you can see well here.
It had rounded towers,
rounded towers.
It had small windows with
arcuations at the top,
as you can also see,
curvature at the top.
And then Ward-Perkins
believes--there's some
controversy about this--but he
believes it was already
crenulated in the third century
A.D.
If you compare that to the gate
as restored by Honorius and
Arcadius, you can see that they
have removed one of the
entranceways.
There's a single arcuated
entranceway now in the center of
the gate,
and they have also encased the
rounded towers in these square
blocks,
as you can see here,
they've left the uppermost part
rounded but not the bottom part.
So they have changed it
somewhat, but I think it still
gives you,
again, a very good sense of
what this gate,
and many of the other gates
that were part of this very
important defensive wall system,
built in the third century,
looked like.
What we see happening toward
the end of the third century
A.D.
is the return of a centralized,
of a strong,
centralized government to Rome
and to the Roman Empire,
after the bloody third century
A.D.
and its numerous fly-by-night
emperors, as I call them here.
And the vehicle of this return
of a stable government was the
foundation of what we call the
Tetrarchy;
the Tetrarchy,
which means literally four-man
rule.
The Tetrarchy was the
brainchild of a man by the name
of Diocletian.
Diocletian was a Dalmatian;
not a dog, but somebody who
came from ancient Dalmatia,
now Croatia,
from Dalmatia.
He was an imperial bodyguard
who rose to great heights and
eventually became emperor of
Rome.
He began his own rise to power
in 283 A.D.; 283 A.D.
But it was in 293,
after ten years into trying to
go it alone,
that he realized that the Roman
Empire had become much too vast
for one man to be able to govern
it alone,
and he came up with this
extraordinary idea to have
four-man rule.
We've seen co-emperors before,
we've seen two-man rule--
there was two-man rule
initially with Marcus Aurelius
and Lucius Versus,
for example--but we have never
before seen a four-man rule.
But he felt that the Empire was
sprawling enough that it really
needed emperors in four
different locations to enable
the Empire to be governed and to
enable stability to be returned.
And that was the concept of the
Tetrarchy, which again he
founded in 293.
By founding the Tetrarchy,
he made himself the main
emperor,
the Augustus,
but the Augustus in the eastern
part of the Empire,
and I'm sure he chose that
because of his own roots in
Dalmatia,
in again what is now Croatia.
He chose a man by the name of
Galerius to be his Caesar,
to be his second-in-command,
in the eastern part of the
Empire.
He selected Maximian,
Maximian to be Augustus in the
West,
and then Constantius Chlorus to
be the Caesar in the West:
Constantius Chlorus,
more well known as the father
of Constantine the Great than he
is as a Tetrarch,
but he again,
Constantius Chlorus,
was the designated Caesar in
the West.
Order was restored through the
vehicle of the Tetrarchy.
And what that means for us,
in this course on Roman
Architecture,
is that stability returned,
stability that enabled major
architectural commissions to
once again be done,
both in Rome and also around
the provinces,
and particularly in the
provinces that these individuals
made their capitals,
in a sense, and where they
lived, and where we'll see they
built their own palaces.
So when we speak of tetrarchic
architecture,
I think we have to keep in mind
that we are talking not just
about the renovation of Rome--
I mean, Rome itself,
the renaissance,
let's call it that instead of
renovation;
the renaissance of Rome,
Rome's rebirth under the
Tetrarchy and under Diocletian--
but we are also talking about
architecture,
as we'll see,
that was put up in the
provinces,
also under the aegis of the
Tetrarchs.
I want to just show you what
the Tetrarchs looked like,
and their portraiture is also
illustrative of what their major
architectural agenda was.
We see a coin portrait on the
left-hand side of the screen of
Diocletian,
that gives his title,
Augustus, as you can see here:
a typical Roman coin profile
portrait that shows him with a
closely cropped military
hairstyle and beard.
But the much more--and he is
represented this way in his
coins, you know,
from 283, the first decade from
283 to about 293.
But the image that becomes the
image of the Tetrarchs as a
whole is the sort of thing that
you see here.
We begin to see,
with the formation of the
Tetrarchy, representations of
them as a group.
It's sort of a one for all and
all for one concept,
that they are shown in mutual
support,
holding each other,
in fact embracing each other,
in mutual support as they try
to re-stabilize the government.
This is a wonderful group
portrait of the four Tetrarchs.
It's done in this
reddish-purplish stone that
comes from Egypt called
porphyry,
p-o-r-p-h-y-r-y,
and a stone that we'll see used
extensively in this period.
This portrait is carved out of
that.
We don't--we have thoughts
about where it might have come
from, perhaps even
Constantinople.
But it ended up in Venice,
and any of you who make your
way to San Marco in Venice--
it's not immediately obvious
where it is,
but if you stand in front of
San Marco,
facing it, and go off a bit to
the right,
you will see this incredible
porphyry group,
hugging one corner of the
building over here.
And again you can see
them--it's done--what's
interesting to us,
I think, is the fact that it's
done in a very geometric
abstract style.
It doesn't look realistic.
They are done--their
proportions are stumpy and their
bodies,
their military costumes and
their faces seem almost more
like--
and the hats that they wear,
these Pannonian caps--
seem almost more like geometric
shapes than they seem like real
clothing and the like.
And that is part and parcel of
a certain aesthetic that we see
developing, this interest in
geometric and abstract forms,
that we see in portraiture.
But we also see,
which is important for us
today, we see that in
architecture as well,
that interest.
And I think--and perhaps it's
going too far,
but I don't think so--I think
that the taste for that
particular formulation has to do
in part with this,
the fact that they believe they
have returned,
or they're trying to return
stability to the government,
so they choose these very
solid, geometric,
abstract forms to represent
their images --
be they portraiture or be they,
as we'll see,
monumental works of
architecture.
Perhaps it's not surprising to
see that when Diocletian begins
to put up monumental
architecture in Rome,
he chooses first public
monuments, public monuments that
are going to be seen and that
are going to speak to this
return of stability to Rome,
and he chooses to put them in
as visible place as he possibly
can.
And what's the most visible
place in the city of Rome but
the Roman Forum,
the great Forum Romanum.
So we see Diocletian
commissioning a monument to put
up in the Roman Forum.
That monument is referred to by
a variety of names.
We usually call it--and I've
indicated this for you on the
Monument List--
we usually call it,
the preferred name for it is
the Decennial Monument,
the Decennial Monument.
But it is also sometimes called
the Five Column Monument,
and it is sometimes called the
Tetrarchic Monument.
It's called the Tetrarchic
Monument because it honors the
four Tetrarchs.
It's called the Five Column
Monument because it's made up,
as we'll see,
of five columns.
And it's called the Decennial
Monument because it honors the
decennalia,
the ten-year rule of the
Tetrarchy;
the Tetrarchy founded in 293,
the monument is put up in 303,
so ten years of rule.
And it also honored the
twentieth anniversary,
the vicennalia,
v-i-c-e-n-n-a-l-i-a,
of Diocletian,
because Diocletian had become
emperor in 283.
So he's lasted twenty
years--which is extraordinary
considering some emperors of the
third century only lasted a
matter of months--
he's lasted twenty years,
and his Tetrarchy has lasted
ten years.
And it's time for a
celebration, and he puts up a
major monument in the Roman
Forum.
Let me show you via this map
first, this plan of the Roman
Forum as it would've looked
between the third century and
the seventh century A.D.
We see a number of buildings
that we have looked at together
before.
We can see in the uppermost
part the Tabularium,
the Temple of Vespasian.
We see the Arch of Septimius
Severus up here.
We see some buildings we did
not talk about;
for example,
the Temple of the Divine Julius
Caesar,
and a couple of basilicas that
were put here in the late
Republic and into--
and finished in the Augustan
period.
The two buildings that we're
going to look at today are the
Senate House,
or the Curia Julia,
but also at the Rostra,
or what's behind the Rostra.
You see the Rostra there,
right in the center;
that's the dais from which
major speeches were made.
If you look right behind the
Rostra, you will see four
columns on a curve,
and then another column right
behind them.
That is the so-called Five
Column Monument,
of the Tetrarchy,
that we see there,
right behind the Rostra.
Now here we're looking at a
Google Earth image,
from the same vantage point,
that shows us again the
Colosseum,
the Victor Emmanuel Monument,
the Capitoline Hill,
the Palatine Hill,
the Circus Maximus.
Here the Forum in the center.
And we can locate the Five
Column Monument by--
let me see, here we have the
Curia,
here we have the Arch of
Septimius Severus,
and then right next to the Arch
of Septimius Severus,
essentially to the left of it,
was the location of the Five
Column Monument,
right behind the Rostra.
Now the problem is that all we
have left of this so-called Five
Column Monument is a single
base, one base of one of the
columns.
And you can see that base on
display,
right in front of,
on a base, right--
on a base, on a different base
made out of brick,
as you see here--the base of
that one column,
right in front of the Arch of
Septimius Severus,
dwarfed by the Arch of
Septimius Severus.
In fact, I'm always on the
lookout when I'm in that part of
the Forum to see if anybody
looks at the column base,
and nobody ever does,
they're so taken both with the
Arch of Septimius Severus,
with the Baroque church that
lies behind and with the Curia
or Senate House that we're all
going to look at today,
that they don't happen to
notice this.
But that is all that survives.
So you might ask yourself,
well then how in the world do
we know there was a five column
monument behind the Rostra,
and that this is one of those
columns?
Because we have a depiction of
it on the Arch of Constantine,
which we'll be looking at on
Tuesday, the early
fourth-century A.D.
arch.
One of the scenes that shows
Constantine himself,
is located in the Roman Forum,
and we see Constantine,
now headless,
with some of his attendants and
other individuals,
standing on the Rostra,
making an address to the
people.
He's surrounded--this is very
interesting,
we'll talk about why next
time--surrounded by seated
portraits of Hadrian and Marcus
Aurelius,
identifiable by their
portraits, and he's making an
address.
And if you look very carefully
you will see behind him are five
columns;
five columns that have statues
on top of them.
That is the Five Column
Monument that stood behind the
Rostra.
So that, combined with that
preserved base,
gives us a very good sense of
what that monument might have
looked like.
Now you may be asking yourself,
"What is she talking
about, five columns?
There are only four Tetrarchs.
Is she misspeaking here?"
No, I'm speaking correctly,
there were five columns,
but one of those columns was
put up to Jupiter,
Jupiter: the head god,
Jupiter who was the patron god
of Diocletian.
So we see Jupiter in one column
on his own,
back behind the others,
and then the other four columns
of the Tetrarchs,
each with a base with
sculptural figural decoration
down below.
The shaft was plain,
and then a statue of each of
the four Tetrarchs and a statue
of Jupiter on the top.
And we think that the column
and statue of Jupiter were
probably a little bit taller,
as is indicated here,
because he was after all a god,
than the others.
And you can see the way it is
located behind the Rostra,
so that again if someone were
speaking from the Rostra,
this is exactly what you'd be
seeing behind,
just as we see in the Arch of
Constantine.
You also see its location,
as it faces the Temple of
Divine Julius Caesar--which is
probably not a coincidence;
we do see that Diocletian tried
to link himself to Caesar and
others, great leaders of the
Roman past--and then this
basilica completed by Augustus.
This was a very carefully
chosen location by Diocletian,
to link himself,
after this bloody third
century,
as I mentioned,
to link himself with the great
leaders of the Roman past.
I want to show you quickly,
because this is again,
of course, in architecture and
not in sculpture,
but I do want to show you just
quickly the scenes on the base.
Because I think one of the
interesting detective work one
can do is to try to figure out,
since we have only one base,
whose base was it,
which of the four Tetrarchs,
or was it Jupiter's base?
And I've played that game
myself, and I'll give you my
idea, and you'll see whether you
think it's a good one or not.
We look at the scene at the top
uppermost part –
we're looking at the four sides
of that sculptured base.
At the top you see two
victories, with a shield,
and that shield has the word in
the center,
decennalia,
decennalia:
that's how we know it's
dedicated to the decennial
anniversary,
ten-year rule, of the Tetrarchs.
You can also see barbarians
down below, so a reference to
those who have been conquered.
And if you look very carefully,
you'll see that the figures are
outlined in the way that we saw
them at Orange and also at St.
Rémy.
And then some of the items,
including the arms and armor,
are actually inscribed,
carved, on the stone,
directly on the stone.
So this very interesting use of
outlining here.
Here I don't think the reason
for it is the same.
I don't think they're looking
at copy books,
but rather that there has
been--there's now an interest in
this kind of outlining for
visual effect.
Up here we see a sacrifice of
three animals being brought in
for sacrifice,
and the men with their axes who
are going to slit their throats
ultimately --
the sacrifice obviously in
honor of this decennial
celebration,
this anniversary celebration,
making reference to ten-year
rule of the Tetrarchy.
Here's a scene down
here--unfortunately,
in all of these scenes where we
seem to have the emperor or
emperors, the heads are no
longer preserved.
So here we have a sacrifice
scene, also a sacrifice being
made in honor of this decennial
anniversary,
but the emperor,
represented here,
who was sacrificing,
whose base this probably was,
his face is gone.
But you can see he's
accompanied by Roma,
by the Senate,
the personification of the
Senate,
by Mars, by Victory,
who crowns him with a wreath,
as you can see here.
And this looks like a figure of
Sol Helios, with the rayed
crown.
So a whole panoply of
divinities by whom he is being
honored and with whom he wants
to associate himself.
This is the most important
relief, I believe,
in terms of speculating about
whose base this might have been.
We see four figures,
four adult males,
in the foreground,
with togas, all of them
headless unfortunately.
But four of them--that's no
coincidence, all four standing
there.
So while we see one of
them--this is his base--one of
them sacrificing here;
I guess one could argue it's
Diocletian as the head of the
Tetrarchy, that would be another
possibility.
But the four of them
represented here.
But if you look very closely,
one of them is accompanied by a
child.
So my speculation would be
since one of them is accompanied
by a child,
and since it is Constantine who
was thought most likely to be
the one to eventually succeed
the Tetrarchs,
or become a Tetrarch himself,
I would speculate--
and this is pure
speculation--that this may have
been the base of Constantius
Chlorus,
of his father Constantius
Chlorus, and that the clue there
is Constantine.
Another building that
Diocletian was interested in,
in the Roman Forum,
in terms of associating himself
with Caesar and also with
Augustus,
was the Senate House.
The Curia Julia it is called,
the Curia Julia:
because it was actually not
built in the Diocletianic
period,
but built initially--begun by
Caesar,
begun by Julius Caesar to
provide Rome with a Senate House
in the Roman Forum --
begun by Caesar and completed
by Augustus after Caesar's
death.
But the building was--and
that's why it's named Curia
Julia after the Julian family,
that Caesar,
and also Augustus,
were a part of.
But that building,
the Curia Julia,
was destroyed,
very seriously destroyed,
in a fire in Rome in 283 A.D.
And so what Diocletian does is
he restores it between 284--
he begins already in 284,
well before the formation of
the Tetrarchy,
and he completes it in 305
A.D.; this restoration.
It continues to be called the
Curia Julia,
but it is at this point a
Diocletianic building,
but one that clearly--where he
instructed his designers to try
to keep it as close to the
original as possible.
Now what you're looking at here
on the right-hand side of the
screen is a coin that comes from
the period of the emperor
Augustus,
and it purports to represent--I
don't think there's any question
that it represents,
given its inscription and so
on--the Senate House in Rome,
as it would have looked as
completed by Augustus,
and he's in fact celebrating
the completion of this monument,
and associating himself,
through this coin,
with his divine adoptive
father, Julius Caesar.
If we look at the form--if we
look at the exterior of this
monument,
as it is depicted on the coin,
you will see that it is a
regular square,
the front of the building looks
like a square,
with a very large pediment at
the top,
although I think that was
accentuated here,
its size, in order to allow the
die cutter to include the
sculpture in the pediment,
and also the sculpture
decorating the eaves.
We see the doorway right here.
We see there seems to be a
triple window,
up above the doorway.
And if you look very carefully
you will see that there seems to
be a portico,
a series of columns,
that are there to relive the
severity of the otherwise very
geometrically ordered
façade.
So that's what we think it
looked like in the time of
Caesar, based on that coin.
You see it over here in plan.
This is a plan of the forum in
Rome, in the Augustan period,
10 A.D.
We see the buildings that were
there at that time:
the basilicas;
the Temple of Divine Julius
Caesar;
the Rostra, but of course
without the Five Column
Monument;
no Arch of Septimius Severus.
But we do see the Curia.
And you see it here in plan as
a very plain,
open, rectangular box,
in a sense.
So even in its Caesarian and
Augustan beginnings,
it seems to have been a very
straightforward,
matter-of-fact kind of a
building.
This is a restored view of what
we believe it looked like after
the restoration by Diocletian.
You won't be surprised to hear
that the materials were
different,
that it's a building--in its
restored version it was made out
of concrete faced with brick,
exposed brick.
So very much a building of its
own time.
It would not have looked like
that in the time of Caesar and
Augustus.
But they have,
in every other way,
they have kept to the
underlying geometry of the form,
to the use of the triple window
with a curved top,
as you can see here an arcuated
top,
a pediment up above.
We don't know whether the
second version had pedimental
sculpture in it,
or other decorative sculpture.
The doorway down below.
But the severity of the
brick-faced,
the exposed brick façade
has been alleviated somewhat by
the placement of marble
revetment at the bottom part of
the wall,
behind a series of columns.
So they have kept that portico,
that set of columns,
to relive the severity,
but also to make this building
look,
as much as they could,
like the original Caesarian and
Augustan structure.
This is what the Curia looks
like today.
It is extremely well preserved,
as you can see.
Yes, it's lacking its marble
revetment, and it's lacking its
portico.
But in every other way you can
see very well exactly what this
building looked like in the time
of Diocletian:
concrete faced with brick,
with the very simple windows,
and this very geometric,
abstract ordering.
Which again I believe--you
know, I think the explanation
for that is twofold:
one,
that they are trying to
maintain the look of the
original Julian building,
but also because this is again
the aesthetic of the time,
this decision to make buildings
in a very geometrically ordered,
abstract way;
I believe again to reflect the
stability of their new
government.
This building,
the Curia Julia,
owes its excellent condition to
the fact that it,
like so many buildings we've
talked about this semester,
was reused over time.
We know that it was turned into
a church already in the seventh
century B.C.;
that it was restored in the
twelfth and in the sixteen
century A.D.--did I say seventh
century B.C.?
If I did, I meant A.D.;
seventh century A.D.;
twelfth and sixteenth
centuries, and then again in the
seventeenth century.
And it was in the seventeenth
century that it,
like so many other Roman
structures,
was transformed into a Baroque
church by an architect by the
name of Martino Longhi the
Younger--
I've put his name on the
Monument List for you,
Martino Longhi the Younger--and
it was re-consecrated as
San'Adriano,
Saint Hadrian,
al Foro Romano,
San'Adriano al Foro Romano,
Saint Hadrian in the Roman
Forum was the church.
And when I say Baroque church,
I mean a Baroque church.
It was deconsecrated by
Mussolini in the 1930s,
Mussolini returning it to its
original ancient form,
as you can see over here.
But this photograph shows the
work that was being done in the
'30s to dismantle this Baroque
church into which the Curia had
become.
I mean, it's really hard to
believe that this was the Curia
in the seventeenth century,
but that's exactly what it
looked like,
as well as in the early
twentieth century.
And you can see a bell-tower
had been added,
buttresses had been added to
the structure,
completely encasing the Curia
in a Baroque church.
And we see that being
dismantled in this view over
here.
And I have a view I can show
you also of the interior.
This was the interior in the
seventeenth century;
impossible to see that original
simple box-like interior that
was there in the time of
Diocletian,
and probably there in the time
of Caesar and Augustus,
so filled is it with the usual
Baroque paraphernalia of
elaborate stucco work and angels
flying to the skies and these--
not that we haven't seen this
kind of thing in Roman
architecture,
we of course have.
But you can see that the
original shape of this
particular building has been
completely disguised by Martino
Longhi the Younger as he redoes
the Curia as a Baroque church.
This is--when they took all of
that Baroque accretion off,
this is what they ended up
with.
This is what the Curia looked
like--
probably very similar to this
in the time of Caesar and
Augustus--
what it looked like under
Diocletian,
and what it again looks like
today.
You can see from this view this
very simple, box-like shape for
the interior of this structure:
plain walls;
a coffered, a flat coffered
ceiling;
the only light brought in by a
series of very simple windows,
with arcuated tops,
allowing light into the system.
And then down below--again the
brick facing,
the concrete and brick facing
exposed--
but with the down below
probably some marble revetment
on the wall down here.
Very simple niches,
arcuated and rectangular
niches, but very,
very simple ones.
And then here you see the
benches,
the stone benches,
on which the senators would
have sat when they were
deliberating--
or stood in front of,
because they got up a lot and
orated--
but stood in front of when they
delivered their speeches,
or sat.
And then down below the
original marble revetted floor
is still preserved.
And I can show you two views
here, in color,
of that floor,
to give you a sense--
all done in marbles,
marbles brought from different
parts of the world.
But the usual colors that the
Romans liked for most of their
marble pavements,
a white or off-white,
maroon, green and black,
but very nicely done for
this--very simple,
very geometrically ordered,
but very beautiful interior.
With regard to public
architecture,
Diocletian also built a major
bath in Rome,
following the lead of Caracalla
and many emperors before him,
to provide for the Roman people
a place where they could go and
enjoy themselves,
as well as learn.
Because you'll remember that by
this time these major imperial
bath structures--
and this is one of
those--placed the bathing block
inside a much larger precinct,
that included rooms around it
that served as lecture halls and
meeting halls and seminar rooms
and places for Greek and Latin
libraries and the like,
and we see that same scheme
being used here.
The baths were built between
A.D.
298 and 306 by Diocletian in
Rome.
They're located near the train
station today;
so very close to those
remaining fragments of the
Servian Walls.
And you see again that plan
here.
And you see that the outer
precinct has one of these large
hemicycles that may have been
used for performances,
as you can see,
and that it is like the other
imperial baths that we've looked
at,
with the central bathing rooms
in the center,
in axial relationship to one
another,
and in the usual sequence,
and then with other rooms
disposed around them on either
side,
in a symmetrical way.
We see at Number 4 the
natatio or swimming pool.
We see--which has a scalloped,
the bottom side,
as you see it here,
is scalloped,
the wall is.
Number 3 is the
frigidarium,
the cold room of the baths,
which had a triple groin
vaulted ceiling.
From there we go into the
tepidarium;
you see it here,
a small circular structure with
radiating arms that give it a
cross shape.
And then down below a very
interesting caldarium,
because we see that Diocletian
and his architects have rejected
the round caldarium,
with the radiating alcoves,
looking so much like the
Pantheon,
as we discussed,
and almost as large,
from the Baths of Caracalla.
They've rejected that in favor
of a more rectangular shape,
that's more similar to the
shape of the frigidarium,
but with radiating apses that
have a series of columns that
allow views and vistas from one
to the other.
This is another version of the
same plan, from Ward-Perkins in
this particular case that shows
again the natatio,
the frigidarium.
Here you can see better the way
in which the circle becomes a
cross shape for the
tepidarium;
and then here the
caldarium below,
where you can also see better,
I believe,
the columns on those alcoves
that allow views,
both from inside out and
outside in.
And here still another one.
This is the one that you have
on your Monument List that shows
you those spaces,
once again from the other
direction.
The natatio,
where you can see very well the
scalloped wall;
the frigidarium,
where you can see the
triple-groin vault;
the tepidarium with its
round shape and radiating arms;
and then most importantly the
caldarium with probably
also triple groin vaulted,
just like the
frigidarium,
but with radiating alcoves;
and then all of these other
rooms disposed among them
symmetrically.
Now what's very interesting
also, in terms of more
architecture in later times,
is the Baths of Diocletian were
also reused,
but in this case not for a
single building but for a
variety of buildings,
including a major museum of
antiquities,
a planetarium,
and also a church,
the famous Church of Santa
Maria degli Angeli,
Saint Mary of the Angels.
Now while this plan is still on
the screen,
I want to show you when the
Church of Santa Maria degli
Angeli was redesigned--
and one of the redesigners,
by the way,
was Michelangelo--when it was
redesigned what they did was
they took the alcove--
from where we're standing the
bottom alcove of the
caldarium--
they used that as the curved
façade of their church.
They used the tepidarium
as the vestibule.
They used the
frigidarium as the main
space of the church.
And also and they--and so that
becomes the church,
that main, the bottom part of
the caldarium,
the tepidarium,
and the frigidarium
become the church.
And then some of these other
spaces are used again for other
kinds of buildings,
including a planetarium.
I call your attention
especially to the ones at the
upper right and the upper left,
both of which are octagonal
spaces,
as you can see comparable to
earlier octagonal spaces under
Nero or under Domitian.
And one of those rooms,
this one to our right,
but to the left when you're
facing the entrance to the
church today,
is still very well preserved;
and I'm going to show you that
in a moment.
First here's a view into the
church,
into the nave of Santa Maria
degli Angeli,
which again what you're looking
at is the original
frigidarium of the Baths
of Diocletian.
You can see all the things one
usually sees in a
frigidarium,
and I show you a restored view
of what we think the
frigidarium of the Baths
of Caracalla looked like in
antiquity.
And you can see there's a close
resemblance between the two.
The groin vaults are still
preserved.
We see original columns here,
granite columns,
with capitals--some of the
capitals are ancient,
some of them are not--and we
see a lot of color,
just as we would've seen in the
original Baths of Diocletian.
One difference is that we see
the groin vaults in the Santa
Maria degli Angeli are white,
and that is the work of
Michelangelo.
Michelangelo decided that he
wanted something much plainer
for the vaulting of Santa Maria
degli Angeli,
and it was he who stuccoed it
over,
and no one ever dared to change
Michelangelo's work.
But another architect by the
name of Luigi Vanvitelli,
V-a-n-v-i-t-e-l-l-i--love the
name,
Luigi Vanvitelli--was at work
in the Santa Maria degli Angeli
interior,
in the eighteenth century;
precisely in 1749.
He came in to spruce up the
decoration,
and it was Vanvitelli who added
to the original Roman granite
columns,
who added these mottled--you
see these mottled pilasters;
I'll show you a detail of them
in a moment with their
capitals--some new capitals to
match the ancient Roman
capitals.
He added a lot of the stucco
decoration that you see here
now,
and a lot of the altarpieces
were put in,
in the seventeenth and
eighteenth century,
to make it the church that it
needed to become.
But if I show you a detail of
Vanvitelli's work,
you can see--you know,
as you stand in Santa Maria
degli Angeli,
one tries to figure out what's
ancient and what is modern--
but you can see here what seems
to be a granite shaft,
from an ancient column,
with a new Corinthian capital,
designed by Vanvitelli,
that imitates those,
the Roman ones that are there.
But all of this mottled work,
and all of the stucco
decoration that you see over
here, added by Vanvitelli in the
eighteenth century.
But you've seen enough Roman,
ancient Roman architecture,
especially of the baroque kind,
to know that this sort of thing
did exist in Roman times.
And I think Vanvitelli has
actually done a pretty good job
of giving us a sense of what the
figidarium of these baths
would have looked like in the
time of Diocletian.
Now here's the façade,
and so you see exactly what I
described before.
This is one of the alcoves.
You can see the concrete
brick-faced alcove that they
have--I mean,
this is the simplest
façade of any in Rome.
There's nothing quite like this.
But it's so typical of the
Italians to take wonderful
advantage of what there is.
And so in this case they
decided best to leave it as it
is;
it speaks for itself.
They just use that alcove.
They added a couple of doors,
created a niche,
slapped the name,
Basilica Santa Maria degli
Angeli,
on the front,
very simply,
put a cross at the top,
and this became the
façade into the church,
and it has remained this,
to this day.
Here's another view of the
Baths of Diocletian,
as they look today.
We're looking at the outside,
where we can see the outside of
the frigidarium,
with its windows and its groin
vaulting exposed on the outside.
This is the tepidarium,
and the roofing of the
tepidarium.
And over here you can see the
curved façade that's--
the part of the
caldarium that survives
uses the façade of the
church.
And then as you stand here,
if you go to the right,
you can go and look at what one
of those octagonal rooms looks
like today.
And what they've done,
they've taken advantage--this
is a spectacular space.
This was just--we don't know
exactly what purpose this served
in the bath originally,
but it's actually a space
that's more similar to the
caldarium of Caracalla's
Baths than it is to anything
else in the Baths of Diocletian.
But you can see that they have
taken advantage of this
extraordinary octagonal shape,
with radiating alcoves,
going back to Nero's Domus
Transitoria,
Domus Aurea,
to use as a place to display
some of the greatest works of
sculpture in the part of these
baths that now serves as a
museum.
One very interesting feature
though that I want to point out
to you,
that will be important for
something later we talk about
today and for Tuesday's lecture,
is the fact that you do see
them using here windows in the
lower part of the dome:
windows,
arcuated windows,
to allow light into the system.
We see this development in late
antiquity where they move from
providing light through the
oculus to providing light
through a series of windows.
And again they're sophisticated
enough in their use of concrete
to be able to do that,
and we see that's a trend.
Diocletian was as interested in
private architecture as he was
in public architecture.
He was a man--you can tell a
lot about him just from what
I've told you.
He was very organized and he
planned ahead for his own
abdication eventually,
his own retirement,
and he wanted to live
ultimately back where his roots
were,
on the Croatian,
on the Dalmatian Coast.
And he built for himself a
palace in a place called Split,
in what is now Croatia.
And I show you again the map of
this part of the world.
If you look at Pola,
that we--I can't reach it from
where I am,
but if you look at Pola,
where that is,
and down the Dalmatian Coast,
you'll see Split,
right below that.
Dubrovnik is at the base.
This is actually a view I took
of Dubrovnik,
just to give you a sense of
this part of the world.
It's magnificently beautiful
there, and one can imagine why
Diocletian was drawn to return
to his homeland for his palace.
So we are looking here at the
plan of the Palace of
Diocletian, which is extremely
well preserved;
this is from Ward-Perkins.
And you should be immediately
struck by this palace,
because it--which dates,
by the way, to 300 to 305 A.D.
We see here something that I'm
sure you've all noticed already,
and that is that he has built
this palace in the form of a
Roman castrum;
it's a Roman military camp.
It is a little city;
it's a city in its own right,
in the form of a Roman military
camp.
Why did he do that?
That's interesting.
Well I think it had something
to do with the fact that the
structure was located on the
sea,
right on a promontory on the
sea, and could easily have been
attacked.
And times were still--he was
still--
he had brought stability back,
yes,
but he was very aware of what
had preceded him,
in the third century,
and desirous of protecting
himself and his possessions in
his palace,
on the Dalmatian Coast,
and so he builds it in the form
of a castrum.
You can see all the elements of
a typical Roman military camp,
just as we saw in city
building, urban planning,
from the Republic on.
It's rectangular in shape.
It has walls.
It has watchtowers;
you can see they are
alternately rectangular and
octagonal watchtowers.
It has entrances and exits.
It has a cardo and a
decumanus that cross at
the intersection of the palace.
You can see there are--the main
gateway is on the northern side;
the southern side faces the sea.
As you walk from the northern
entranceway,
along the cardo and the
decumanus,
so to speak,
of this palace,
you will see that they are
colonnaded,
just as they usually are in the
eastern part of the Empire,
but not in the western part of
the Empire.
As you walk along from the
entranceway, you enter into a
public court over here,
very elaborate,
that's still preserved,
with an arcuated lintel;
I'm going to show you that in a
moment.
Then into this domed area here,
with alcoves.
But note that on either side of
this open space,
with the arcuated lintel,
which is called the peristyle
of the villa,
you can see on one side a small
temple,
which is a temple to Jupiter,
the patron god of Diocletian,
and on the other side a
mausoleum, an octagonal tomb.
Now that should strike you as
very interesting and very
unusual.
We have not seen a tomb as part
of palace architecture before.
This is new, to late antiquity.
This probably has to do in part
with again Diocletian planning
this as his place of retirement.
He knew he was going to retire
there,
he knew he was going to die
there, and he wanted to make
sure that he supplied for
himself a tomb--
he was not going to be buried
in one of these major mausolea
in Rome;
he wanted to be buried at home,
and so he plans for this by
building an octagonal--
not a round,
like Augustus and Hadrian--
but an octagonal tomb,
with a porch here in the villa.
And note that it is right
across from the Temple of
Jupiter;
no coincidence there.
Go through the domed room,
domed space,
into the private wing of the
house.
You see a room here with a
basilican shape.
We're not exactly sure what it
was used for,
but probably some kind of
reception hall.
And then here a series of
interestingly shaped rooms,
that was where the emperor's
private quarters were located.
This is a restored view of what
this fortressed palace would
have looked like,
when it was built in the fourth
century.
We see here all of the things
I've already described:
the outer walls;
the watchtowers;
the entranceway on the north;
the colonnaded streets.
You can see the octagonal tomb
rising up over there,
across from the Temple of
Jupiter;
and then down here the private
area, the private wing.
And you can see how the
southern side faces the sea,
and there seems to have been an
arcuated lintel on that side.
We've seen that that's grown in
influence and importance since
it was first used in the time of
Hadrian.
This is the Porta Aurea,
or the northern gate of the
palace.
You see it in a restored view
from Ward-Perkins.
Rectangular entranceway,
lintel, window-like,
with grates above;
niches on either side,
with arcuated pediments.
But most interestingly is the
upper tier where you see a
series of columns on brackets
that support arcades.
This whole idea of arcades on
columns began,
as we know, later in antiquity,
and continues to be important
into the late third and early
fourth centuries.
We saw it at the Severan Forum
at Leptis Magna,
where you can see again
columns, this arcaded colonnade
here.
We saw it in residential
architecture at Ostia,
late residential architecture.
Think of the House of Fortuna
Annonaria where we have those
columns with arches above them
that separate the fountain court
from the triclinium.
So I just wanted to make the
point that we see it not only at
Diocletian's Palace,
but it's very common in late
Roman residential and civic
architecture as well.
This is a view of the peristyle
as it looks today.
We are walking--we've come from
the North Gate,
we're walking along,
we're hitting the peristyle.
We're going to be going from
the peristyle into that domed
area here.
Imagine views through the
columns of the peristyle--
and some of those columns are
still preserved,
as you can see them,
the original columns--
views clearly of the Temple of
Jupiter and of the Mausoleum of
Diocletian on the other side.
Arcuated lintel here inside a
complete pediment.
So that scheme also used as the
major decoration of the
peristyle in the Palace of
Diocletian.
Here's a view of what the small
Temple of Jupiter looks like.
We're looking--it originally
had a statue of Jupiter;
now it has a statue of St.
John the Baptist.
But you can see the shape --
very much like the Curia,
a box-like shape.
Very simple,
in this case not with a flat
coffered ceiling,
but with a barrel vaulted
coffered ceiling.
But again very simple,
very geometric.
And we can see that that barrel
vault is exposed on the
exterior.
We can see the shape of the
barrel vault from the outside,
as well as from the inside.
Here a view of the octagonal
tomb.
The plan of that tomb:
an octagon with colonnade
around it;
columns on the inside;
radiating rectangular and
curved niches.
But a porch,
the whole idea of the
porch--not unlike the Pantheon,
except that it's octagonal
instead of round--porch on the
front;
deep porch;
freestanding columns;
façade orientation;
single staircase.
So this is very similar to
things that we've seen earlier.
And two quick views,
one an engraving of what the
mausoleum,
the octagonal mausoleum would
have looked like,
with its--you can see it's
faced with stone--
with its entranceway
façade and staircase.
And here you can see it is very
well preserved still today,
in Split, where you see the
surrounding columns.
You can see the octagonal shape
and the stonework,
all still very well preserved,
as is the interior.
The interior very ornate,
with columns projecting from
the walls,
supporting these projecting
entablatures,
deeply drilled,
dematerialized,
in the baroque manner,
with lots of sculptural
decoration: representations of
victory and death--
victory over hunting and
victory in war--
and consequently this close
association,
as we've seen,
among all of those.
And then scenes of both,
with a portrait of Diocletian
and a portrait of his wife,
Prisca, both of those being
carried in these wreaths,
up to the heavens,
by flying cupids.
Here's another view,
perhaps a better one that just
gives you some of the sense of
the over-decoration,
over-ornamentation,
the baroque effects of the
interior of the tomb.
So a very different feel to the
Temple of Jupiter,
than to the Tomb of Diocletian
himself.
Here he's gone all out and
commissioned the most ornate
possible decoration,
with all the baroque effects
that we've described,
in two tiers,
for the interior of his
mausoleum.
I want to show you a succession
of other palaces,
each fairly quickly,
other palaces that were built
during this period,
that may have been--well in
some cases we know for sure,
but in other cases we're not as
sure whether they were in fact
palaces for the Tetrarchs.
This is the one that's the
least certain.
It's a palace in the western
part of the Empire that we
believe may have been the palace
of Maximian, Augustus in the
West.
And in fact I should--yes,
so let's look at that first.
And that dates,
as you can see from your
Monument List,
to sometime in the early fourth
century A.D.
Now if you look at the plan of
this quickly,
you will see that it is very,
very different in feel from--
and in plan--from the Palace of
Diocletian at Split.
This may have something to do
with the personality of
Maximian,
or whoever the commissioner
was, but it may also have to do
with the fact that this is not
on the sea but in a remote town
in south-central Sicily,
which was much less likely to
be under attack than the palace
at Split.
In fact, as you look at this,
you must be reminded,
I'm sure, of the Villa of
Hadrian at Tivoli;
it is very similar to that:
a sprawling villa with a series
of very interestingly shaped
rooms,
spread across the terrain,
interacting with nature,
just as they did at Hadrian's
Villa at Tivoli.
Very much a countryside villa,
and I think Hadrian's Villa
clearly the main model.
As we walk through this
axonometric view,
you see we enter on the western
end.
At 1 we see a horseshoe shaped
vestibule, with columns all
around this villa;
just like Hadrian's Villa at
Tivoli, does have a lot of
columns.
We see those here.
Then you make an abrupt right
into this passageway here,
at 2(a).
Then into the peristyle court,
with columns all the way
around;
a pool in the center,
an interestingly shaped pool in
the center;
and then a series of living
spaces, to either side.
On 2(c) we see a transverse
corridor,
which is very important because
it links various parts of the
villa to one another,
but it was also very decorated
with mosaics,
many of which are preserved;
and I'll show you those in a
moment.
2(d), with its niche at the end;
probably a kind of audience
hall;
3 is where the private
compartment is for the emperor,
and you can see that that too
is fronted by a small horseshoe
shaped area.
Then over here,
at 4, we see a tri-lobed dining
room;
the main dining room of the
house with the triple lobes.
And then down below a forecourt
for that that is oval in shape.
So some very interestingly
shaped rooms,
and where we see a combination
of the interest in curvilinear
shapes,
just as in Hadrian's Villa,
and in the use of columnar
architecture;
references to Classical Greece.
Over here, at 5,
we see several rooms,
very interestingly shaped
again, that make up the baths,
the private baths of this
particular place.
One can visit it still today.
Parts of it are very well
preserved.
We're clearly looking at the
peristyle court with the pool in
the center of it,
right here.
And again it is particularly
well known for its mosaics.
We see a long corridor here,
with those mosaics.
They depict primarily scenes of
hunting, and I show you a couple
of those scenes here.
And there's been some
speculation that this was not
Maximian's,
that it may have belonged to
somebody who,
like those individuals who had
the Hunting Baths at Leptis
Magna,
whose work it was to collect
wild animals from Africa--
Africa is very close to
Sicily--collect them from Africa
and send them,
to supply them to amphitheaters
around the world.
But even though most of these
scenes are hunting scenes,
the most famous mosaics from
the Palace of Maximian,
so-called, at Piazza Armerina
in Sicily,
are the so-called bikini girls,
and I show you the bikini girls
right here.
And there's nothing like this
mosaic anywhere else in Roman
art.
But you can see why they're
called the bikini girls,
and they are involved in all
kinds of athletic activities.
One of them has received a
crown and a palm branch for her
excellence.
This one is twirling who knows
what here.
These two are
playing--passing--playing ball.
And over here we see a woman on
the left with her five-pound
weights, working out.
So, I mean, this is probably as
close as we get to--
one doesn't--this is very hard
to interpret exactly what this
means and what it's all about
and why it's here.
But perhaps we can see it as a
kind of women's version to the
mosaic that we saw in the Baths
of Caracalla,
with the famous athletes of the
day;
I mean, perhaps these were
famous women athletes of the
day, some of whom were good
enough even to be awarded
prizes.
But the jury is out on exactly
what these were and why they're
there.
But they're memorable,
these inimitable bikini girls,
and very, very famous -- along
with the Alexander Mosaic,
probably the most famous mosaic
surviving from Roman antiquity.
Again I want to show you just
very briefly,
to give you an inkling of a
couple of more palaces.
One of these we know for sure
is the Palace of Galerius in the
northern part of Greece,
the Palace of Galerius.
Galerius, as you'll recall,
was the Caesar in the eastern
part of the Empire,
to Diocletian.
And I should mention--I think I
neglected to mention--that
Diocletian did,
by the way, abdicate on the 1
of May in 305 A.D.
He voluntarily stepped down,
and when he voluntarily stepped
down, two new--the Caesars were
elevated to Augusti,
and two new Caesars were
chosen;
two new Caesars were chosen.
And Galerius became an
Augustus, and he built for
himself this extraordinary
palace in northern Greece at
Salonica.
And we can see from this
plan--and I've given you the
date of it, to 297 to 305 A.D.;
I've given you a plan of it,
and you should be,
even though only part of it
survives,
you should be immediately
reminded of palaces that we've
already looked at,
not just today but in the past.
Think of Domitian's Palace on
the Palatine Hill.
There's a hippodrome here,
just as Domitian's Palace had,
although Domitian's Palace,
it was used,
as you'll recall,
as a sunken garden.
We're not sure how it was used
here, but we think it may have
actually been used as a circus
here.
Other rooms,
including an octagonal one,
with alcoves,
looking sort of like what
Rabirius designed,
again for Domitian's Palace on
the Palatine Hill.
But up above we see,
just as Diocletian's Palace at
Split, it includes a tomb.
Galerius has also provided for
himself and his afterlife by
creating a round tomb.
You see the uppermost part in
this plan from Ward-Perkins.
And then very interestingly,
just like Diocletian's Palace
at Split,
you can see two major,
what look like major roads,
colonnaded roads,
colonnaded streets,
that intersect in the center,
just like Diocletian's Palace.
And then in the center of that,
where they intersect,
there's a four-sided arch that
I'm going to show you in a
moment, that's still preserved.
Here's a plan of the Tomb of
Galerius, at his villa ,
in this case round with
radiating, rectangular alcoves.
You see it here.
It's actually very well
preserved.
Here's the interior,
showing again,
just as we saw in the Baths
of--the octagonal room in the
Baths of Diocletian,
use of windows in the second
tier, right at the base of the
dome,
rather than an oculus.
And we see that also very well
in plan.
In fact, there were two sets of
them, as you can see here.
So they've abandoned the
oculus in favor of these
windows at the base of the dome.
And then from the outside you
can see that here they have used
concrete faced with brick for
the exterior of the structure,
which was turned into a
church--and you can see some
mosaics from when it was turned
into a church--
and a minaret was also added at
one other point in time.
Here's a spectacular view of
the tomb as it looks today in
Salonica.
You can see it here;
the exterior,
as well as its relationship
along what would have been one
of those colonnaded streets,
with the arch,
which is in part preserved --
the so-called Arch of Galerius.
You can also see from this view
how similar modern Salonica is
to modern Athens:
same country,
same World War,
post-World War II construction;
mostly residential houses of
five, six, seven stories,
white in color,
with balconies,
as you can see.
Here's a view of the
relationship of the tomb to the
arch.
These two colonnaded streets
that intersect,
and at that intersection the
placement of the arch.
The arch was four-sided so the
streets could go underneath it.
But it was also triple-bayed,
as you can see here:
single, central large bay;
two smaller bays on either side;
and then the piers decorated
with sculpture,
that give us a report on the
exploits,
the military exploits of
Galerius in the eastern part of
the Empire.
These were Galerius' wars,
Galerius' victories that are
depicted here.
But we do believe that since it
was one for all and all for one,
that it honored the Tetrarchy
as a whole as well,
and that there were niches that
were placed somewhere on this
arch,
that would have had in them
representations,
portraits, of each of the four
Tetrarchs.
Another view of the Arch of
Galerius, at Salonica,
where you can see its
relationship,
even today, to what was once
the Tomb of Galerius,
here.
And a more detailed view of
some of the scenes,
and how crowded they are,
with one rectangular panel,
piled one on top of another,
and decorative motifs in
between them.
And if we look at a detail,
we see the usual scenes that we
see on things like this:
the emperor sacrificing;
the emperor on horseback,
trampling barbarian enemies;
the emperor seated,
with the other Tetrarchs down
here, and with a host of gods
and goddesses and
personifications.
So again an honoring of
Galerius' own personal
victories, but an expansion of
those to include reference also
to the Tetrarchy as a whole.
We're going to be talking next
time about two men in
particular: a man by the name of
Maxentius and Constantine the
Great.
Constantine the Great,
as I've already mentioned,
was the son of Constantius
Chlorus.
Maxentius was the son of
Maximian.
So we see the generations
continue, and the sons of the
Tetrarchs also want to be
Tetrarchs themselves,
if not sole ruler.
And we'll see Maxentius and
Constantine do battle against
one another in Tuesday's
lecture.
But I just want to
mention--we'll talk about
Maxentius in some detail next
time,
especially his construction,
or the beginning,
his beginning construction on a
great basilica in Rome,
that Constantine eventually
finished,
the so-called Basilica of
Maxentius/Constantine,
or the Basilica Nova.
But I want to mention just in
passing today a villa,
about a villa that Maxentius
built in Rome,
on the Via Appia in Rome,
just to round the circle and to
show you that some of these
palaces were still--
they were being built in these
capitals elsewhere in the world,
but were still being built in
Rome.
And we know that Maxentius
built a villa in the early
fourth century A.D.,
as I said on the Via Appia.
And there are some remains of
it today.
I show you a general view of
those here,
and a view, from the air,
from Ward-Perkins I believe,
that shows you that part of
that villa,
which is still preserved,
was another one of these
hippodromes, the circus.
And in this case we know that
this circus was used as a
circus--horse races took place
here--and that it was built to
hold 15,000 spectators;
15,000 spectators to come out
onto the Via Appia to see horse
races at Maxentius' villa.
We also know that this villa
had a tomb that Maxentius
provided for himself,
and perhaps for his family as
well, inside his villa.
So we see the same idea that
we've seen in the provinces,
being used in Rome
concurrently,
a tomb that is not all that
well preserved,
but there is enough where we do
believe it was a kind of mini
Pantheon.
And I show it to you here in
two restored views that give you
a sense of what it would have
looked like: that it was indeed
a mini Pantheon;
that it was round;
that it had a traditional porch
in the front,
with columns and pediments,
deep porch,
freestanding columns,
single staircase,
façade orientation,
domed as you can see here.
This one looks like it
reconstructs an oculus,
although I don't think we're
absolutely sure that this
structure had an oculus;
which seems an unlikely thing
to do with a tomb anyway,
to have an opening in the
ceiling and rain coming,
water coming into that tomb.
But leaving that particular
detail aside,
we believe it was in the form
of the Pantheon.
A better preserved tomb that I
can show you,
that seems to have been quite
like it,
is this last monument that I'm
showing you today,
the Tor de'Schiavi,
a restored view from
Ward-Perkins,
that was a tomb that was put up
in around A.D.
300 on one of Rome's other
major streets,
the Via Praenestina,
as I've indicated on the
Monument List.
And once again we see this
whole idea of the mini Pantheon,
being used not as a temple to
all the gods,
but as a tomb;
as a tomb, a round structure
with a traditional porch on the
front,
a rectangular pediment,
deep porch,
freestanding columns in that
porch,
single staircase façade,
emphasis here.
You also see,
interestingly enough,
that this one we know did not
have an oculus,
and you can see that they have
put windows at the base to
provide light.
These are not the usual windows
that we've seen,
that were arcuated at the top,
but rather round windows,
sort of portholes,
into this particular tomb.
Up above you see the plan,
as in Ward-Perkins,
round with radiating,
alternating curved and
rectangular alcoves.
There is some controversy about
the porch, whether it had a
regular, complete,
triangular pediment,
or whether it had an arcuated
lintel.
We're not sure.
Various scholars have put
forward one view or the other.
But the last thought that I
want to leave you with is that
it's very interesting to see
these mini Pantheons being used
as tombs in late antiquity,
by the Tetrarchs and by others,
and if not mini Pantheons,
octagonal structures that also
look back to the past.
And I think that's important,
and it's a nice note to end on,
because it reminds us that when
Diocletian and the other
Tetrarchs come into Rome,
after the chaos of the third
century A.D.,
and want to establish
stability--once again,
re-establish stability--what do
they do?
They look to the past.
They build buildings in the
Roman Forum,
but they also look to the great
architecture of their earlier
counterparts,
of Caesar--of the great leaders
of the Roman past--
Caesar, Augustus, Hadrian.
They look to them,
they look to their buildings,
and they use their buildings as
models to indicate that they are
in a line from those earlier
emperors,
that they're just as much in
control,
that they have brought
stability back to Rome,
and also to the Empire as a
whole, which is why we see them
building not just in Rome but
also around the Empire,
as they govern from the
fringes, as well as they govern
from the city of Rome.
Thank you all.
Have a good day.